[Music]
total honeymoon vibes right now
it was literally one of the greatest
moments of my life obviously but
i mean it was beyond what i thought it
was going to be
gwen gushed about her big day with blake
and revealed how she said yes to the
dress
discovering the stunning custom vera
wayne gown i tried on
one dress and then i was like i don't
know that didn't feel right and then i
tried another one on i was like
that's the one and then i just went with
it gwen's two eldest sons kingston and
zuma both reportedly signed the couple's
wedding certificate
as witnesses to celebrate her two-week
anniversary
gwen posted this black and white wedding
photo and
this is kind of funny some fans wondered
if that was former president trump at
the i deuce
yeah no just a lookalike guest and while
gwen may be
feeling the honeymoon vibes what about
an actual getaway
yeah that's on hold the hard-working
newlyweds will hit the stage together
for cma summer jam next tuesday in
nashville blake kicks off his boot
stomping 16 city tour in a month
and of course he's back on the voice in
september alongside another newlywed
ariana grande and when she told the
podcast
tell me about it with jade iovine
there's a new album coming in eight
shows for her vegas residency
in october
just trying to decide if i want to write
some more songs or not and have some
other stuff
up my sleeve